welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz today i'm
delighted to be joined by matt hogg who
is the managing director of wallace
hinds matt started his recruitment
career in 2000 and started his crew with
the high street agency in which he
progressed his career from trainee to
branch manager
then in 2005 uh sorry 2004 he joined
wallace hind where he is obviously still
currently and he's progressed from
consultant all the way to partner before
actually successfully achieving a
management buyout three months ago
so matt now is in charge of the
strategic growth of the company as he
looks to carry on the brand but also
build a new chapter so there's currently
20 people
within the business they're based in
northampton and matt has big plans to
take the business forward grow the
company and uh thank you for joining me
on the podcast matt
you're welcome that was a belting intros
better than uh better than my wife knows
me so thanks for that well um
loads loads for us to go into but where
we always like to start yep is
in your opinion what what
characteristics and traits do you feel
really make up a highly successful
recruitment consultant
for me it always came down to two very
very basic things uh and and that's
purely resilience
uh and determination to keep going it's
you know in our job we say no no we get
told no and we say no 99 of the time
um so
you've just got to keep going if you you
give up too easy you'll you'll fail in
this sector i mean that can apply to
lots i'm sure but every good consultant
i've ever worked with has just had that
single-minded
determination and the resilience to keep
going when it's tough did you did you
have that
from the very beginning of your
recruitment career do you think
i'd like to i'd like to think so um
you know i imagine you'd have to ask
some of the mentors and some of the
people that i that i worked with but i
was lucky to have some really
high caliber
uh individuals or i thought they were
high caliber that that just said
snippets to me very early which i still
use today i still use it when i'm
coaching and training people today
um
because it made sense to me and you know
i think as soon as that
you have that light bulb moment or it
just drops and you get it
then
it makes it a lot easier um okay
if you know if you've been through some
not hard times because that makes it
sound like you know we're not getting
shot at and you know we're not in the
armed forces or anything so
um
but yeah that you know that resilience
is absolutely key for me so
what why i was really keen to to speak
to you which was we've discussed before
we started recording this was
obviously your journey with wallace
heinden this sort of recent management
buyout that and that journey that you've
been on
i think a lot of people listen to this
will be
within the recruitment business where if
they progress their recruitment career
that that may be something that's on the
table and maybe a carrier that's being
dangled in front of them by the the
owners of the car the company they work
for and then also at the same time
there'll be people listen to this that
have their own recruitment business that
um would see this as either like a great
option for them to actually sell the
company
um or an option that they actually
really like the idea of because the
story can continue
uh and then they've given their
leadership team a great opportunity to
to carry on um with the business
so
we're definitely gonna like go into that
in detail so um but where i just wanted
to very quickly start
was just
early days
of your recruitment career so you
started in the high street environment
um
is that fair yeah
yeah yeah yeah i i walked into their
business one day sold them some ad copy
and uh the branch manager turned around
to me and said oh ever thought about
doing recruitment and i had no idea what
recruitment was i'd work for agencies
when i was a kid
um you know stuff in envelopes factories
i thought that's all what agency was uh
and at the time i thought yeah why not i
mean it's something different um i think
i don't know about today's recruiters
but certainly i think a lot of my
generation of recruiters
that's how we got into it you know we
went to register with a recruiter or you
sold somebody to them and someone
somewhere went
do this
um
so uh so yeah and you know i started in
it was a pretty big
um high street they're not around
anymore they um they got purchased and
then sold and a couple of times but
yeah i um
i i really enjoyed it it was fast paced
it was just the people element was was
what yes so let's just i guess if we can
try and maybe try and condense
those first four years like what
obviously you clearly what what's what's
always happened that looks like is
you've uh really taken the opportunity
to progress your career
um it looks like obviously you've worked
in two companies but both times
you've really been someone that
hasn't stayed stagnant and sort of taken
opportunities internally if that's but
yeah like becoming a branch manager
becoming a director these things so like
how what were some of the things that
you were talking about some of the
things that you learned from other
people that you still use now what were
some of the things that you learned in
those four years that have really
remained or stuck with you do you think
that
could be interesting for people to to
learn from or or hear about yeah
are you you're making me give away my
trade secrets that's what it says come
and work for me and i'll share
everything we're growing uh yeah best
best advert ever uh but
it was
um
it was the freedom
well
you weren't the credibility to gain the
freedom to have a goal i was never
afraid of having a go we were talking
about this yesterday i took my first
ever job on on my second day i had no
idea what i was doing
and called this company they said oh
yeah we're looking for i can't remember
what it was and i said and i passed my i
passed my handset to my branch manager
and said oh yeah let my secretary take
the details and then i'll come back to
you
who does that
um that was bizarre we i can't remember
if i filled the job or not but uh she
gave me a clipper and that was when you
were allowed to get a clip around the
year by the way as well so um said don't
ever call me your secretary
um
but it was um a phrase that i use a lot
and that i was told back then that i use
now
is if the marriage breaks down you don't
blame the vicar tell us more right and
as recruiters
we are putting two people in a room you
know we can't take any credit if i
placed you in a job and you were amazing
i can't take any credit for how amazing
you are post placement that's down to
you and the company and if it fails
after 9 months 12 months i'm not taking
you to work every day i'm not coaching
you training you
so that phrase of you know if the
marriage breaks it's the two people in
the marriage that make it work not the
victim know the vic is pretty important
all the way through but ultimately day
one together
you know you're there and and that just
stuck with me
to understand the role that i played as
a part of the recruitment process
um
and then the second thing was
uh well the second really important
thing was it's not personal
it's never personal you know people
don't want people to say no to you not
because they know you and your family
and your beliefs and your morals they're
saying no because
they haven't got any vacancies or they
don't want that job it's you know this
is people's careers and again as soon as
that clicked
that
you know this is someone's career you're
talking about
um
[Music]
you know it made a big difference and it
i i stopped taking things so personally
so so i hear that i think that i'm sure
you've seen this show up in
people that joined your journal joined
um what is hand but like what what's
your advice for people that maybe are
finding themselves maybe there might be
early on in their career and they're
finding themselves taking a lot of the
things personally that person accepting
the counter offer or that person not
showing up for an interview like what
what's your advice to me if you find if
i'm in your team and you're just seeing
these things really affect me and take
it personally i know it sometimes
doesn't just happen overnight but what
would your advice be for me and it can
be lots of little things and they just
niggle away at you
what we can do is is look at your
process look at what you're doing can
you do everything that's in your control
you know now if you can control the
things that are in your control
fantastic
but unless you are picking dave up and
taking him to his interview and dropping
him off you can't control if he goes you
know with those of us that have been in
recruitment a long time the the volume
of grannies and aunties funerals that
have happened on the day of an interview
uh for reasons for people not to attend
this is incredible but
you've just got to you know this is
someone's career if you can look back at
did you
check the interest of the job did you
call them to wish them luck did you know
that they had other things going on and
if someone takes a counter offer
they feel it's right for them
not personal to you
if you've done your job properly
then you can hold your head up high i
mean that was one of the
we switched to a retained model 10 years
ago and that was one of the big things
that also helped people not take it
personally because in the nicest
possible way you get the job the next
candidate gets you i still get paid so
yeah
i'm not biased on whether you get it or
someone else because i'm i've been paid
so
i'd say if you can
if you haven't done something that's in
your control
own that make sure you don't do that
don't make the same mistakes over and
over again
if it's physically outside of your
control ex except that it's outside of
your control because otherwise this job
will drive you yeah i think that's
and i think the the sooner you can have
cultivate that mindset the better
because because i think yeah that whole
idea of like
like you said being willing to look in
the mirror and go right what
firstly understanding what parts of the
process do i control or uh that and then
once you understand that it's then like
okay let's actually obviously one of
them
the guys that we have
involved with recruitment mentors one of
the sessions that he done which you uh
is probably quite common is he he just
calls it like the postmortem of like a
deal or a deal that fell out and then
you like you said you break down that
process and go right
what what what was it on my shoulders
that i didn't maybe do so well with or i
could improve that's what you should be
focusing on rather than this this
such-and-such as happened which was out
of your control yeah
the only thing i'd say to people is do
the post-mortem on every every yeah okay
because when it's gone well what have we
done well we focus as sales
professionals people focus on the
negative far too much you know we've got
a 95 success rate with filling our
vacancies every single company i pitch
to go oh what about the 5
now i've got to come back to that but my
point is if you can look through a
process
and think oh do you know what i got away
with one there because i forgot to call
it pull him or her or you know i forgot
to call the candidate to wish them luck
or i forgot this i forgot that
then
you know
it makes you makes make sure you don't
make those mistakes next time so post
mortem the bad stuff absolutely post
more than the good stuff let's put
ourselves on the back when we get it
right because
like i say 99 of the time it's you know
we've got no vacancies no i'm not
interested no i'm sorry i can't progress
your hashim you're not right for the job
there's this one vacancy
and if you get 400 applicants you're
saying no 399 points yeah
so it's a really good point yes it's a
great it's a great it's a great um
thing to be doing on a consistent basis
looking what you did well we didn't it's
again you will then call event like a
reflective mindset like most high
performers that i've interviewed they
they sort of incorporate this in their
weekly monthly
um
sort of reviews of like right what what
has been working what hasn't been
working
uh because it can be very easy to get
complacent and do what has been working
but and then you're just like i'm gonna
keep trying to do the things that have
always served me to get what i mean so i
think it also sort of encourages that
self-awareness and sort of
self-reflective mindset which most high
performers have or are willing to do
but
most training programs will talk about a
reflective element you know
and don't focus on those elements are
breaking it down but ultimately what
happened
you know and that's the post-mortem
thing that your colleagues talking about
what have actually what happened and
then you can say
what was what was good what was bad what
can i improve what was out of my control
um we've all made placements where
it's you know you've thought crikey how
the hell did that happen
but you know it makes up for the ones
that you you absolutely think that
you've you've nailed everything and
something goes wrong something out of
your control so let's
let's take this into what is time then
so we're really excited to sort of dig
into this
mbo journey so let's just sort of frame
this up for people so like what what did
she join the business in 2004 what what
did the what did the company look like
when when you joined it
so wallace has always been a a boutique
recruiter the guys that set it up
yeah were x
um
you know they all were for a big
national a big national recruiter that
again people of a certain generation
would know those that those names aren't
around anymore so you know you wouldn't
know them but
and and they just thought this can be
done better you haven't got to work till
nine o'clock at night you can earn a
good you can earn good money provide
great service but you can go home at
five o'clock
um and particularly in northampton again
we're you know we're going back sort of
15 20 years but you know before job
boards were you know a huge thing if you
wanted a job you either went through a
recruiter or you looked in the paper on
a thursday or a sunday or whatever it
was so
um
you know wallace hind had a fantastic
reputation locally you know if you come
up again i used to come up against them
all the time and lose because they were
better
uh they were more credible better
experienced and and they were just
always for me this business that were up
on a hill and i always thought if i left
the company i was with
i was never going to go to another high
street because it's just
the same job in a different brand
um
i had a i had a i have a 22 year old
daughter now i'm that i'm very proud of
but um yeah so i had her i was very
young and i was finding that
she was in she was asleep when i got up
in the morning she was asleep by the
time i got home at night and i was
missing out on her growing up so
uh i thought i was never gonna go to one
of the cities
um so i joined this place and it was
um
it was like uh my eyes opened to what
recruitment is because i was feeling
credit control jobs and receptionists
and different stuff
yeah i did the i did the where it was
commercial high street you know so the
biggest salary i think i ever worked on
and again we're going back to 2000 yeah
so yeah inflation yeah
yeah yeah the biggest salary i'd ever
worked on was 25k and i thought i was
the
dogs watson in the office
um
the first the first job i i worked on at
wallace heim was a
42k national sales manager
um and i didn't realize this because the
info was wrong in the crm system but
i got the company to travel travel over
from ireland to interview here in
northampton and i had candidates travel
from wales
um
birmingham i'd sort of four candidates
travel from all over the country here
because that was it was the way i was
that they taught me to do it i said no
the clients come here to interview
candidates come here to you don't go out
anywhere
and it was like almost
this bravado um and it
it
it's almost snobbery it wasn't snobbery
but it almost came no no no these guys
need us more than we need them so they
should come to us we're the
professionals so oh okay and i just
followed that and as soon as you start
pitching and selling that in that way
companies they buy into you and believe
you
and they're right so so so how so let's
just so let's just paint in the picture
then so how how big was the company when
you joined it like what what did it look
like uh
it was probably doing a turnover
of around a million pounds we've only
ever been one site we employed
i'm getting i mean yeah we weren't
maybe similar numbers probably maybe 20
22 people you know i remember them
saying you know we want to get what they
when i joined their their
dream was to have
2 million turnover and
20 billion consultants and then support
staff
um and it always feeled like it always
felt like a
you know a reach
because it was doubling their turnover
it was doubling the stuff that they've
done before and how many how many how
many uh founders were there how many
people started the business
three so three original founders uh
started the business back in 92 and they
had a silent partner um who was in fact
mr hind
i don't i don't know who that wallace
was uh
yeah
so he so he invested half the money and
the other three guys uh
and uh whether they're lost you know
they'll see this or they'll be on golf
courses
or wherever now
um
where john gowan
uh jerry bell and mike causley and mike
still mike and jerry actually to be fair
still involved in the business um
but they
their original idea apparently was gbh
recruitment
now those three initials stand for
something else so i'm not sure
you know
you know what what goes really well with
hind and that they came up with with
wallace hinds uh and another colleague
who joined very shortly sort of added
the selection because you know we
we're not we're not bums on seats we're
selection we select people it's it's
going out and finding them and finding
and it's a process not
a you know not a chair not a not a
battery 10 thing so it became well
assigned selection cool so that that's
what the business looked like when you
sort of first joined
so let let's just go into the the
timeline of this let's just go into this
mbo journey because i think that's what
people will be most most interested in
and i think what's also really exciting
for what is high now and moving forward
so
so that's where it was when you first
joined
like when yep when did it sort of when
did you start first i guess
start realizing or becoming aware that
this was a business that you could
potentially in the future
be
a part owner of or however like when did
that first light because obviously
you've been at the company for over a
decade so like when when did it first
start because i think some some people
will have these aspirations some won't i
think a lot of people will will have
this carrot dangled in front of them if
that's like an employee share share
scheme or like the like that's a big
scale right it's like matt you can come
join what is high and be part of the
journey
you can end up owning part of the
company etc so like when did this first
start
becoming a potential reality for you do
you think how long ago
okay um but we we do that by the way uh
that's something that that we do and and
the business is always done and i'll
absolutely pass forward so
i guess in terms of the actual mbo
we got to
20
we were absolutely flying in in 2009 and
then got smashed by the the global
crisis and it took a few years to
to get that back but probably
2015 2016 we hit that
number of staff we hit
sort of two million pounds um
rather than three founders doing little
bits you know an md had been one of them
stepped up as md so we became more
professional we had
training and and
that's really
to that point because i was i'm
10 12 years younger than the founding
partners i suppose
i always said i want the next step i
want to be a part of it
if you pay me more great but i'm not
interested that i want to be a part of
the strategic development and the stuff
and
um
so 2015 2016 we started talking about
exit strategy you know these guys are
getting into their mid-50s and they
wanted to
you know call it when when can we call
it a day and realize the the 30 years
hard work so
how did that even like talk to us about
when we started
like what would that conversation look
like was it is it down the pub and we
were talking like candidly was it like
quite professional did you sort of bring
it up no it was uh i i'd say it was a
mixture you know we were
sat in in the boardroom at the boardroom
we're in a beautiful we are in a
beautiful vigorous but we're in the
largest room that we have that we
christened to the boardroom um because
wallace heim was set up as a partnership
so there were actually
when i first became a partner there were
uh
there were ten right okay
i know and only 25 staff
so
um
and that's when you know
it certainly wasn't me but i'm pretty
sure
um in one of those meetings somebody
um sort of talked about exit strategies
because they'd always talked about maybe
selling at some point
um but nothing serious
and that
started me thinking started the md
thinking and then the very next meeting
we said right well our exit strategy is
x you know and it went around the room
how long people wanted to stay whether
they'd be interested in taking it on how
would they feel about a sale
um
what that would look like the three
founders obviously had their own
conversations because they had a bigger
stake
uh and we took the decision that
um in one of those meetings took the
decision that
they would offer the opportunity for
anybody to put their hat in the ring to
do an mbo
um
that was from yeah that was your partner
um
yeah
and they were going to invite they paid
a
commercial sales business recruitment
specialist commercial sales business to
come in audit the company and take us to
the market
so
um myself and a colleague
sat down looked at it
felt that we were the right age right
experience we had some good credibility
in the business had some had loads of
drive and passion to where we wanted to
take it
um because the founders will openly
admit when they got to two million when
they got to that goal it was like yay
we've done it
and and you got me and a couple other
people brilliant what's next
no nothing's next we've done it all
right well
i'm 40. what do you mean i've got
i've got i've got to do
um okay
so so you know kind of that that helped
as well but the the you know the team
here are brilliant um
you know but i
obviously never done an mbo before
worked with lots of clients so i started
talking to
hr directors managing directors owners
financial directors of businesses that
i'd supplied people to and people that i
trusted
you know what are the pitfalls of doing
this where do i start
um
what's involved what well so and i got
some great advice for some from some
people that i trust
uh
you know
immensely
um okay and we put a plan together and
and sat down and started doing the
hardcore okay cool
thanks for sharing that so okay so let
let's just break this down a little bit
then so
so that was around the time yeah as you
said you actually started to go on this
journey it's around 2016 as you said
then
so at that stage again just to paint a
picture for people because i want to try
and make it just as easy as possible for
people to relate or like compare it to
where they're at in their teams and
stuff so like
what was a what was the structure then
so are you all completely planned
business did you do some contract is it
all permanent yeah no we're so wallace
hinds 100 perm business it's split 2016
and it still is today it's split 75
retained 25 contingent
um you can probably see the most of the
the categories the different variations
behind me but
yeah um
the challenge yeah so sorry i'll get
ahead of myself but yeah different
verticals we have recruiters that
specialize we have recruit you know i've
always pitched myself as a as a
generalist
um i've got more experience in
recruiting certain functions than others
but
you know i've turned my hand to most
things over the years
um
so yeah it was a hundred hundred percent
cool 100 perm i think the key part there
which i'm interested to find out from
you like how much of an impact it had
was the 75 retained piece so 75 retained
work
25 um contingent
and then also at that point
uh you said that obviously like the md
and you like were really driving it
forward but at that point there was what
10 partners
that could also
go down this path as well could have
been part of the journey
yeah
yeah so there well three found in and
seven uh seven of us uh yeah but so ten
ten in total but the way the percentages
worked you you earn
uh percentage or you you could buy in if
you wanted to once you'd hit a certain
criteria of service and billings and all
the rest of it okay um
and one two three three of those
so so the three founders were always
getting out so it was from the seven
three of the seven
um actually
two of them have been involved since
you know were basically
recruitment number one and number four i
think so they were in a similar category
so we're
probably looking to get out so it only
left
really a few others that were going to
drive an mbo
right um
you know if we had the appetite for it
um
you know so we we sat down as a
as a four
um you know and had some pretty frank
conversations we'd worked together for a
long time and and there was lots of
honesty in there which really helped
um
you know and actually as as it turns out
so two of their founding partners
still here and and they'll they'll be
working for a
couple more years at least and then
two from the seven are also still here
but weren't involved in the nbo so the
actual nbo in the end was myself
and uh at the time
uh three employees four employees
so they stepped up yeah so
before we talk about you going to market
and the learnings and stuff like that
just just to like sort of talk a bit
about this early part so in with
hindsight if i'm listening to this right
now
and
the conversation's been happening it
started the founders the owners of the
company that i work for have said
an mbo's on the table we're open to it
and we like the idea of it and i'm i'm
someone maybe one out of three four
people who are directors associate
directors
um and this is something that me as an
associate director that company i'm
really excited about and i won
so i guess what i'm keen to just get
from you is i know you said there's a
lot of honesty but like in hindsight if
i'm at that sort of stage
what conversations questions
would you be asking
knowing what you know now to my peers
to the owners that you think could i
don't know just help move it forward in
the right direction or and also help
shed light on like is this a reality
that that's achievable don't know what
are some of the things that people
should be asking finding out that you
think is really key at that stage
so
yeah okay great question
um
the first the
the first thing i probably i would have
done probably a bit more research into
it i was perhaps i got i think i got
caught up in the can can own the company
yeah yeah do this we should do this yeah
um there's a lot of work there's a lot
of due diligence um and if you've not
worked
in a corporation if you've not been
exposed you know again i've worked
at that point i'd work for a boutique
recruiter in a little village that no
one's ever heard of for 12 years
i hadn't been exposed to some of this
stuff so
absolutely do your research there's lots
of information out there on online
have very clear goals about what you
want and what you're prepared to
give up and negotiate and what you're
not and
that comes down to the people that
you're going to do this with
working with somebody as a director is
one thing working with them as an owner
is a different kind of fish
you've got to be
you've got to be transparent and really
clear about
your priorities because if me and you
are going to go into you and i are going
to go into business together
if one of your core values absolutely
contradicts one of mine this isn't going
to work
and this is a conversation we will never
have had because we're directors that
work in the same business and yeah
you've got to come and go exactly you
may not have those conversations but
they're necessary so you wouldn't have
had those conversations so yeah they're
necessary you know looking at the team
around you
um and who you're going to do this with
who's going to play what role and why
um
and then making sure that that's
something that you're prepared to invest
100 120 150 hours in outside of your
normal job because whilst you're doing
an mbo you've still i'm still an
employee i've still got a partner i've
still got a number that i've got to
produce um
so
yeah it's uh
it's
i i it's good advice because i think
i think it could be if i again trying to
put our shoes in someone that
has has got this idea or voting part of
the conflict they've absolutely grafted
in like it's exciting right it's
positive it's something to tell your
mates about i'm going to own this
company one day all these things and you
can get wrapped up in that but i think
obviously the advice that you're giving
yeah which you obviously have had to
learn through challenges or maybe even
the hard way is well if i was to go back
and start again
like let's have these really honest
conversations like now at this very
beginning stage
and i think the good thing about that as
well
is that like if you're starting to think
about who's going to do what like what
our values are what's important to us
that also makes it even more real
um when you're having those
conversations yeah yeah absolutely well
it starts as a pipe dream right
um
who's going to lend right so he's going
gonna lend me two million quid to buy a
company
how do i find somebody to let me two
million quid to buy a company um the
next thing that you have to do
is is be very real about the price very
the price
of the company about the commercials of
what you can yeah
yeah because again i'm buying the
company from you you
it's no different to buying anything
else you want as much as you can get i
want to pay as little yeah yeah so let's
go into this part of the journey then so
we've spoken a bit about like the
beginning
so
as you said the obviously founders then
obviously got um i'm assuming i don't
know if this is common practice but they
then obviously got like an impartial
organization to then come in and go like
obviously value the company basically
right yep yeah yeah absolutely and then
to understand how to take them to market
cool
so let's just talk about this like going
to marketplace so just to frame this up
so you are as you were just saying
so if i'm going to go down this mbo path
we would then have to go to market and
find
investors people
companies who are basically going to
fund
and support you and whoever else is
involved in that mbo in purchasing
the majority shares or however it's
going to be structured from the people
that started the company right which is
why you're going to market and you're
basically looking to raise investment
and get that investment is that right
yeah yeah absolutely so let's just talk
about this thing like where like how so
how involved were you then if there was
a company like would you like was you
pitching to banks was you getting in
front of pe firms yeah how involved were
you
100 involved it's you know it's it was
it's me and a colleague
um
that did all of that we're leading the
nbo we were the face of it and then
therefore
you know the like you say the banks we
we pitched to
all of the major banks and a couple of
the
newer ones
we
um pitched to we met i think two pe
companies and
three vc companies and then there was we
were introduced to one or two um
i think they're called angel investors
or business investors and uh as well so
okay um and i'd like to think our our
first pitch versus our 10th pitch
so we'll go into that but just quickly
because i think it's good for context
yeah
i'm not trying to get you to like share
everything that's in like all the
details and stuff but i think it'll just
be good it'd be a good context
so like how much was you how much was
you looking to raise
how much did you look into investing so
and and this is why getting the price is
important the first couple of meetings
we were looking to raise two million one
that was too little or too much um
uh
it was
when we started to learn more about how
those things were structured because two
million yeah we'll take two million well
we want two million on day one
we haven't got two million day one
well actually what number do we want
does that involve the cash in the bank
you know so it was
two million was fine
but it didn't buy
the the cash in the bank or the building
because that's separate
all right so now we need
2.7
oh right
well we haven't right but we can't but
we can't get 2 million without the
building and the cash in the bank
because that's
so
understanding the price and what's
involved before you go pitching so what
did you miss then um
just understand
we we made we made
too many presumptions through lack of
knowledge um
and lack of confirmation about
what what we needed and what it looked
like and again yeah the the guys the the
we did you know the senior guys they
were also very open well we thought that
would just be the case so as we got more
feedback from
from partners and and from banks and you
know and again we were very open about
the facts
and i like to think this helped us
because we got lots of feedback and
support actually i'd say 70 percent of
the people we pitched to gave us right
because you said we haven't done this
before
yeah yeah so you like owned that yeah
absolutely yeah yeah really
look that's
that's important to me in everyday life
right whether you're talking to a
candidate for the first time or talking
to a bank and asking them for two
million quid
this is my skill set this is what i know
and how i know it i'm gonna the reason
i'm talking to you is because you're an
expert
so
understanding that
digging
i know about our financials trying to
talk to
a non-recruiter
about our financials and how it works
they just
we had to come
they just didn't get it
okay
what happens if you don't feel the
vacancy well we do that's what we do and
that's what we've done for 25 years yeah
but what if you don't well then we
we only get two thirds of the money
what happens if they don't pay that well
they do pay that here's all the evidence
of them paying that so with if you're
selling a recruiter and you've got lots
of temps and lots of contractors you've
got a plan that you're selling and those
people are in work with perms it's a lot
harder because once you've done your job
that's it yeah
and there were lots of
lots of that we found lots of challenges
um
less so with the um with one of the one
of the vcs was a recruitment specialist
so they got it straight away and one of
the angel investors had done a couple of
bits with that criminal context
yeah okay
let's talk let's talk about let's talk
about this pitching journey then
let's talk about because i think because
this is this is probably where one of
the steepest learning curve is going to
be so you've spoken around
the presumptions the just yeah because
you haven't done this before
like get get really under the skin of
like what how much money do you need to
raise and all these types of things
so let's just say that we've done that
what what can people like what was you
firstly maybe what would you like most
surprised by when you did some of these
first early like uh pictures
when you did them
oh good question um
uh did actually for me and
my colleague may be different but for me
uh
i was out of my comfort zone
um
you know when i've gone pitch into
customers or i've done
you know talks at seminars or or
days or whatever i'm in control i'm the
expert i've got knowledge it's about
vulnerable so it was that out of comfort
zone yeah absolutely um
you get asked questions that you don't
know the answers to so then self-doubt
comes in especially in situations like
that so
yeah those early doors and and then
that self-doubt then or do i really want
to do this should i be doing this two
million quids a lot of money
you know so
um
what was really helpful
the the fact that the founders were
involved
and all the way through you're really
open with information you know if you're
going to do an mbo
you you've got to have access yeah
because it's in their interests i have
access to if any of that is feeling
difficult then it's like a red flag for
sure
yeah i've heard some horror stories and
and the problem is you you find things
you didn't know about
because because you didn't have access
or it wasn't in your remit to worry
about it before
you know we i was really lucky
wallistown's always been pretty open
pretty transparent business
um
you know and the md was
i think his preference was certainly to
do an mbo over an external sale because
a legacy because of some of the stuff
you talked about um
some of the other founders maybe maybe
not because you know
getting getting half a million quid to
to stick in your bank account and say
terah was good yeah what it's a nice
reward for 30 years so vulnerable sell
okay
got that so
um
in in terms of that then so i guess
let's just try and again hindsight is a
great thing which is what's great about
this podcast
so if i'm
so let's just try and get your advice
for people that might be going on this
like pitching journey then so if i if
i've done my due diligence i've
hopefully really understood what we need
to be raising
um i've i'm working with founders that
are being cooperative they give me the
information that i need
like if you were to
speak to matt before he went on that
pitching journey what what advice would
you give him to hopefully maybe just get
more options get more out of those
pitching opportunities that meant you
had different options to potentially
um achieve the mbo get the investment
what advice would you give yourself and
people that would start that
i'd for ours because
because it was retained and continue you
know we'd have and some of the
verticals that you see behind me and
some of the
before we were just recruiters
and we didn't we didn't put ourselves in
the shoes of the buyer enough to lay it
out to have virtual so they could see
what they buy when you're buying a
recruiter typically you're well lots of
businesses you're buying goodwill
so
i
just got to make sure you put your
yourself in the shoes of the buyer or
the investor
and beast and ask those stupid questions
of yourself
kick out presumption
what does that mean how does it mean it
could you
we should have
gone and pitched to
our wives
our mates people who don't know about
recruitment but better but are in decent
jobs to understand it so that
if they don't get it then
to double check that that presumably if
yeah absolutely if they get the
proposition if you you know we all know
commercial people right
uh so if they can understand the
commercial proposition
then then you're a lot better prepared
um it's not that we didn't know it no
man what we didn't know was what the
other person didn't know
and that that's what that's what killed
us in the first couple i like it i say
killed us it you know they were very
because i think because of the
transparency the humble humility and the
genuine nature of what we were trying to
do
actually
um
definitely
two
three definitely two of the major major
banks were really helpful you know they
push back need to know this this is how
you break it down this and you know they
work with us
to them yeah go again so what ended what
ended up being so two things
what ended up being the most valuable
part of the business
like or part of that pitch or i know
there may not be one thing but like what
because i think that like you were
saying it's a recruitment business so i
think obviously you might tell me it's a
retained piece but i don't know because
it's a perm business it is more
difficult from what i've learned and the
conversation i've had so what ended up
being the part that these investors
were like that's really good or you felt
like was one like the lead domino to go
you know what this is something we'll
consider and then i'll ask you a
question after but that that's the first
thing that comes to mind now what ended
up being like the really
cool things that really got these people
excited about the investment
once they understood the retaining piece
absolutely that was that was key because
again the presumptions around perm and
how the payment structures work um
[Music]
was was critical because it's about cash
flow because we haven't got content
buying a business that doesn't make
anything
it's all good will and the laptops are
worth x
as we found out the building wasn't
involved and we're in a beautiful old
vicarage that was worth x you know that
turned you know there's no assets
particularly so i'm asking for a big
chunk of cash
for goodwill really so
um
getting across
the retained piece how it worked
introducing some of the psl's that we're
on which is you know and how that
historical placements work but it was it
was really
um
[Music]
i think the retained piece was going
because that because hermes is really
challenging
to sell as a business it devalues it it
devalues it absolutely so the next thing
then which i guess segues into like how
things played out and uh all of that is
um
coming to sort of the end here but this
is what we want to do right one's gonna
this would be so helpful for people so
so thank you for like being open and
sharing all this so then the next part
really is then like obviously if i if
you're pitching to me and i'm looking to
yeah fund this mbo obviously then you
need to be communicating in a quite sort
of clear way like how i'm then going to
make x back
or how i'm going to so like how did that
then play out how did them
how what was the strategy around that
how they're going to make their money
back
so it was pitched over a period of time
and it was
linked to profitability obviously again
like like any sale it was linked to
future investment and growth and being
able to achieve some of the things we
wanted to in in time scales
we got um
we didn't get any offers from the banks
um because we we fell through the cracks
yeah they were looking to either lend
more to capital equipment businesses or
or they were dishing out a lot of sub
million pounds and it just wasn't we
were offered a million pounds by the
bank but it wasn't enough to get a
controlling stake so it wasn't worth it
um and we had uh one pe and one vc offer
um and we rejected both of them both the
first one because of
god
can't quantify gut feelings it didn't
feel right i didn't feel right
didn't feel right and i thought this you
got to listen to that just
not using the same language we're not
yeah this guy and the other one the
payment terms were horrific it would
have took us to the wall um
and we didn't feel that we felt that
we'd lose some of our
heritage and our integrity we don't have
so the only kpi a consultant has at
wallace hind is the number that they've
got to achieve over the year that's it
if you do that with one placement one
phone call happy days take the yes a
year off yeah
if they do a million phone calls and a
million placements of a pound each well
you know you're gonna work hard but fine
um
and we thought we
we just felt that we'd lose that element
because we'd have to drive so you know
you wouldn't be able to have any
gears at all it would be black and white
and you know we'd turn into one of those
corporations yeah
so we ended we ended up
rejecting the offers we got
um
and the proposition that we actually
went with was one similar to um
on similar to accountants and solicitors
how they get how they do it which is
where the the business effectively buys
itself over
a five-year period right right just just
let's talk about layman's time sorry
yeah
so we created so wallace hind selection
limited is a brand new organization that
started on the fifth of july
uh we purchased
uh wallace hind selection llp uh for a
nominal figure which was uh which is
that which is
raised or not oh no no no no no okay
sorry this is this is a no no just to
like so it's all the paperwork to attach
changing you think changing yeah yeah
okay right
because it's a sale
um and then you sign
uh we've signed so we've got it lock
stock and barrel for that nominal fee
it's a bit how sometimes how football
clubs are sold
uh so we acquire all the good stuff and
all the bad stuff um creditors debtors
what have you and then we've signed
personal
loan agreements with the founders to
make payments to them
based on a set of criteria over the last
five years got it and that's and then
that's the money so when that's the
money that you raised
and that's the money that so part of
that is the money so there's no
in in this model
you you've got no outside investment to
answer to you've only got yourselves
because it's an agreement between
the new company owners
to and those founders as individuals as
personal individuals and then if you
don't mind me asking so it takes them
they've they've got
that's them really because they don't
get a big payout that they want and if
you don't mind me asking like what what
happens if you don't hit some of those
things what would happen would it would
it be like a costume on you and the like
the the contract's 93 pages
like okay fair so like maybe like the
layman said so there are so so um well
look you know it's
so they can they can for so we've got a
trigger point a profit trigger point
that at the minute we make x amount of
profit um
then that the the next x amount of
figure goes towards paying them and it's
a set fee if we want to pay more we can
but like any personal loan that you have
as a consumer
if you want to pay more you can if you
if we fall below that figure and have a
tough year and we want to pay less then
we sit and have a good meeting and talk
about it
um
they can force through their sum but if
they force through some that bankrupt us
they don't get payments in year two
three four it's still quite
collaborative it's still quiet yeah oh
god yeah absolutely and and um yeah so
one of the three is retired
i like saying um the other two are still
here but one
um one's retiring probably in april and
then the last guy will stay for another
probably two years because he looks yeah
okay bless him
so yeah definitely yeah yeah for sure
okay i love that and then so main
positives i guess high level for them is
yeah
they're not just getting one sort of hit
it's over a period of time
um which i guess is a nice thing
for them
tax-free earnings of some some nice
figures year-on-year for the next five
years uh benefit viewers or sure
well but yeah no the i was gonna say
well the benefit to us is no
we've got no no pressure from a from a
bank or a ve or a sorry a p or a vc
um
you know well i suppose they are yeah
yeah because they're still in the
business they've got visibility of
what's going on that might change in
three or four years when you know
they're just coming to the board
meetings but they've still got uh it's
in their interest for you guys yeah is
that success exactly and that's key yeah
so so who who put up the funds then
was it a
so the business doesn't so the funds
so so because
you know
if we fail
and i'm hanging on to a large table of
woods
right right so you know if
everybody fails
nobody gets paid so
you know there this is a massive leap of
faith for them
in doing it this way but their
alternative was they got they got two
external offers to just to buy uh one
was a low ball which they decided to
reject and the other
um the three of them actually felt a bit
like i felt about the the vc and
something he's just going to strip it
and kill it
um and that didn't sit right with them
and that's a testament to to their
and who could blame you know if you put
your life into 30 years into something
and then you got your payout and you
left that's a horrible feeling some
people will care about what happens
afterwards but some people take their
money and run
uh we were lucky that they were the
fourth yeah okay so just to make it
crystal clear and then we'll wrap up and
just find out what the new chapter what
you're excited by
so like just yeah i just want to make
sure i understand this so
obviously yeah so basically they're
getting that payout which everything
you've agreed over five years so
actually
you didn't actually take any external
investment this is all driven by wallace
hind producing x each year over the five
years but what you've agreed
is those founders will get x per year
and once all that hits then you will
then become
the majority sheldon or the yeah they
will no longer be the majority
shareholders uh well so
because they are because the way we've
driven the contract i'm the majority
shareholder of wallace hein selection
limited is just that their liability
they're our liabilities they're our
debtors we've got yeah yeah so i so the
day i signed that contract
uh because of the stake that i've got um
i was actually saying yes i now own 50
of a 1.6 million pound debt
yeah
yes
that's right yeah well i just explained
so then yeah yeah cool got it
so there's no external investment
there's no
my the the people that i have to report
to my board so to speak or my investors
are the people i've worked with and
employed me for the last 17 years so
talk to us about the next chapter mate
what what have you got on like how will
we take in what is time forward what are
you excited about
what what's uh what was obviously we're
gonna have to make this money well i was
crapping myself all the way through
well it's
yeah well we've got to and you know the
difference is these guys had this this
picture or the ceiling of two million
and then and then the balloon got
deflated when we got there or got popped
and stuff
i want to do three four five ten
there's no limit to it um you know what
what the last couple of years has proved
that there you know you don't have to be
we are in a beautiful old building but
we don't have to be
you know we can have you don't need
multiple locations like these corporate
high streets who have you know 100
locations and then have consultants
fighting you know you can have different
sectors different i mean i'm working on
a job in asia for goodness sake and it's
just a time zone so
you
that it's limitless
you know i want to grow our
i target for that five years it's 50
people about 5 million limitless
i can't can't get that beyond that at
the minute but
you know we want to we want to grow we
want more of these
every function you can think of and
something that i've said to the team
here and and uh the new starters that
we've got coming on board in the next
few weeks is that i was given this
amazing opportunity
if in 10 years time you know i'll pass
that down now if you know somebody comes
along and wants to offer me an awful lot
of money to buy the place then maybe
that's different but my goal at this
point is to is to pass it forward and do
exactly what these guys have done for me
um but i need the people to do that and
it won't be a a 20 person team
and a couple of million quid it'll be 50
a hundred
uh we'll have we'll have hashim as our
podcast director
of
uh recruitment excellence but that's my
point that there's no ceiling i love it
and i don't wanna i i and i wanna get
people into this business that that
think
you know it's commercially it's gotta be
right we're not just obviously chucking
money at stuff but
come up with an idea want it i sat in
every single meeting with my bosses from
the day i started you know what's next
i want to do more i want to be more
involved and that's what i want from
people and not everybody's like that
which is great you need people who are a
thing but
you know
getting
just just own what what you want and and
don't don't set yourself a ceiling
no i love it
well um
matt honestly thank you so much for
sharing that i think that will that
would be so insightful for
so many people which is why i was so
excited to record this conversation with
you and really excited to see where it
is
in uh the next few years now absolutely
love your mindset i think
kudos to you mate on
like
as i'm sure you've been around those
conversations i'm sure many people at
wallace hind early on were down the pub
going i'm going to own this company one
day or i'm going to be this or that and
you've uh you've made it happen mate um
and i know it probably feels like it's
just starting it's just beginning again
but it's it's really exciting and really
appreciate you uh
sharing that all with us and i know
obviously you're always
happy to chat to people with they may be
going through similar things on a
similar journey so yeah definitely
connect with matt on on linkedin if this
is a conversation that you'd really like
to have with matt um yeah congrats mate
and excited to see how it all
unravels
yeah no absolutely well keep in touch
and watching space